hello and welcome we're at the National
Library of India and behind me is the
grand stage for the Grantchester where
we see the best in the world
battle it out but besides that the city
of Kolkata loves chess and this is
pretty clear from what's going on here
just on the ground floor there are 200
kids today participating in the chess
festival every day there are some
activities the kids are having a great
time not only are they enjoying chests
they get to see the best in the world
we had fun all through all through five
days from the 22nd to 26 and last two
days 23rd and 24th we had age group
tournament where 196 pairs took part so
even I mean it's kind of to give them
the opportunity to come play enjoy have
fun at the same time an opportunity to
see the diversity it was like people
from chess peers from all over Kolkata
came over here almost invisible
tournament with many rated players I had
fun in this yes this tournament is very
big and many players are there and there
is a huge and kind of players there is
playing many openings like it that's why
I enjoy playing all there so who's your
favorite player here Magnus I love his
style of attacking well VC is my second
favorite but Magnus is favorite wish me
not an iron because he is always
concentrating on whatever he is doing
and he has a good style of playing chess
my favorite place on his Kiwi yeah he's
very good in end games and I like his
playing styles my favorite player is
Magnus Carlsen because he complicates
and confuses often and easily Magnus can
send he's very strong and chess player
right here these are the champions of
tomorrow Kolkata known as the city of
joy has become the city of chess
you